So today we are going to see my friend is, um, his name is Aria. He,
um, he went to my college and you know,
he's into startups and he's into engineering also. And, uh, it's been a while.
I haven't seen him. So he reached out to me and, um, he wanted to hang out. So.
Yo Joma yo.
Oh man. Oh, and also hate that.
[Inaudible] Oh man. Yeah, man.
It's been like what? College? It's crazy. Yeah.
So you still working for Microsoft? Actually,
I run a startup now. Oh, have you gone through series eight yet? Well,
actually I'm funding myself with Bitcoins. Oh, nice.
Um, so what about you? Where are you up to? Oh,
I just sold another company. I'm just relaxing.
Now I'm trying to figure out what to do next. Like I always think,
why did VCs always choose my companies? You know,
it's actually a hassle or enough choice too much. Yeah. I mean, yeah,
me too. I mean, I totally get that.
Oh, Hey, you still take chats, right? Yeah. I still dabble you're for, uh,
for like a
friendly it's anything but friendly or crush you I'm so rusty,
but I love to love to put you back in the poor house.
I've memorized over 300 openings and practice every day per pass here. Yeah.
Yeah, no, I'm pretty trashed here. Like haven't planned. Wow.
[inaudible]
King scamp it by far my best opening, especially if he accepts it. All right.
I accept you again.
You've activated my trap card.
Little does he know this is my best opening. First I played night F three,
then he responsive G five and then quickly each for the duck.
What is this? You thought I played G five. Didn't you? It's the wagon.
Bok opening and unconventional, but dangerous opening.
Much less studied than the classic variation.
I don't mind a little variation like
[inaudible]
is queen what a blender victory is mine.
Rookie mistake. I guess you haven't improved
on my one more.
[inaudible]
your first employees.
They can either make or break your company for not vine.com.
We have to make sure we hired the right people to build the foundation of our
company. Today. We are joined by my advisor,
Mattoon entrepreneur angel investor, and philanthropist.
He's known to be the Wolf of silicone Valley. All right,
so let's start. So why do you want to work for boring?
Yeah, that works very bold. I like it. Silence is dope.
My parents want me to get out of the house boy,
and I think this is a cool company. So you know,
pretty excited you remember when YouTube had a security hack? Yeah, that was me.
Okay. I am the most qualified person for this job.
I've been studying online video for years between fine Vimeo, YouTube.
I know it all. So what kind of a, so what kind of skills do you have?
I can, uh, write code. Okay. Writing code.
I know Java. I took a class in Java and you know,
I get done. Yeah. I guess that's works.
Yeah. There we go. Hmm. Well, this ain't my only two pythons.
My coach seat sharp. My coats, sexy. Sexiest should be rated R like coincide.
I know, but I know basic. And let's go,
what do you want to work on? I want to be the CTO and hallway deal.
I'm good with anything. I'm just really excited to work on that. Mine.
I really liked buying. So yeah. Full idea guys.
I want to build North line's infrastructure and wants to be the greatest app all
the time. I want to make sure that whenever anyone is that site,
they're having an experience of a lifetime. I'm not going to hack together.
like windows Vista. All right. So the next question, just a formality.
We're going to ask you to do a little bit of a coding.
Question. It's quite simple. Um, here's the laptop, basically what it is is, um,
you have to find the missing number out of a one to 108.
Just start writing the code. Do you want me to, do you want me to coat this?
Um, Joma I thought this was just a formality. This is easiest book.
Do you want me or not? Don't give me this interview. Yeah, that's fine.
Yep. Yep. A boy called Gauss figured this out in 1783.
Um, can I have some water
here? Silicon Valley's finest. Well,
that's perfect. That was quick. Pretty good. I mean,
let's just get to me.
All right. I think I've done
pretty good. It's. Like what do you mean? I mean, they got the answer, right?
It's going to take a million years to run. Yeah. But like,
look there's comments and stuff like that. It's good documentation, dude.
We're done Mark yourself. So they get the job.
All right. First son, me. She's amazing. She's the best? The beauty.
And so far she's solid when it comes to technical skills. A CTO. Absolutely.
What about Cameron? Cameron? He's a straight shooter.
He knows five languages things the best at Python.
He never makes any mistake straight. Harder. All right. Now, John, no, come on.
No, I mean, he's my friend. I can go all night. I know.
I know his code is not perfect and I know he's may or may not be the smartest
guy, but I do think they can add a lot of value to the company.
He does have a lot of heart.
Right.
All right. So I guess we're all good. Then let's build not wine.
What's popping. Now, if you like this video,
don't forget to subscribe and also press the bell because that will give you a
notification. Whenever start-up four will come out.
And if you want to see behind the scenes and you know,
just extra footage or maybe like the director's cut and stuff like that,
I'm going to post it on patron. So if you want to please support me on patron.
Uh, it only costs a dollar a month and you'll be able to see all of the other
content. And also news. I have a Facebook page now, uh,
please like that page because I'm going to use it to do announcements from now
on.
Cause I realized there isn't any good way for me to announce things permanently.
So I'm going to be using my Facebook page to announce things and I'm going to
post extra content in there. Uh, yeah.
So I'm going to have that link down below and don't forget to like it and yeah,
it's going to be great. Lastly, I just want to say thank you so,
so much for 10,000 subscribers, honestly, that number is fricking crazy.
And I just have nothing to say because my goal for 2018 was the
head 10,000 subscribers and I did it in one month. All thanks to you guys.
Thank you so much. Oh, and because I hit 10 K means I've reached 2,500,
5,000 and 10,000.
So stay tuned because I am going to announce another giveaway. All right.
That's it. Thanks for watching again. And thanks for tuning in. See you.
[Inaudible].